you
all right welcome Cynthia to Microsoft
research as part of your your the talk
that he will give in the next hour so
yeah a pleasure to have you here thank
you you know you just get started with
I'd love to you know what got you
started in the whole area of robotics
specially in a social robotics yeah what
were the biggest motivations and
inspirations and tell us about your
initial part of your journey yeah so um
you know I think looking back I can tell
a very linear story when you're living
life it's really not that way I mean you
you go on various branches of your
life's path and you end up you know
where you where you end up which has
been an incredible journey you know but
for me I mean I do think it really
started you know I was ten and the first
Star Wars movie came out and I think you
know today you know kids today don't
understand what a phenomenal and that
was you know it's like I remember
sitting in the theater and the Imperial
whatever galactic star cruise whatever
was like going overhead and like this
seats were vibrating it was just like
this ah inspiring experience from the
very beginning and then these droids
came on the screen and I just fell in
love with them and I think it's because
they weren't just robots like useful
robots but it was really because they
were full-fledged characters they had
rich personalities they had
relationships not only with each other
but with you know the main human
characters and they really cared about
one another and I thought you know that
emotional connection really stuck with
me and you know I think the whole world
fell in love with those robots for a
reason you know and so you know fast
forward you know I ended up doing my
graduate work at the MIT artificial
intelligence lab before it was C cell
where professor rod Brooks was my
advisor and he's recognized as the
father of autonomous robots and I
remember you know when I was
admitted as a graduate student and
looking at the various schools and
deciding where I should go and I walked
into rod Brooks's lab which was then
called the mobile robotics group and I
saw all these little insect-inspired
robot s-- and a lot of the work then was
around biological inspiration of
intelligence and I remember just
thinking oh my god
if those robots and star wars are ever
gonna really become a reality it's gonna
start in a lab just like this in fact
maybe this lab and I'm like I have to be
here so so that was really it and it was
the promise of robots as artificial
creatures you know back then very
inspired by insects but then you could
imagine the evolution of that and you
know we thought we would go from insects
to like reptiles to like I don't know
mammals or whatever and then eventually
maybe eventually maybe you'd get to
people but I remember when rod went on
sabbatical he did this world tour and he
came back and he's like we're doing
humanoids and we're like what we just
got and it's because he spent time as
part of that in Japan and he had seen
all of this humanoid work and you know
back then the reason why humanoid
robotics was so important in Japan was
just they were already grappling with
this profound shift right where the
ratio of working age people to retired
age persons was was going to hit their
country harder than in many other
countries and they were already thinking
about robots right as a way of helping
to to bridge that gap but humanoid was
because so much of our human engineered
space was about this bar follow gee
walking around tools everything was
built for this mythology so that's why
you wanted humanoids and I remember the
day that I was still in graduate student
NASA landed
you know robots on Mars and I remember
thinking you know cuz then the value
proposition of autonomy was about the
dull dirty and dangerous far from people
right that was why you did autonomous
robots and I remember thinking to myself
all right here we are we send robots
into the oceans we
them into volcanoes and now we even land
them on Mars why aren't they in our
living rooms and it was that moment that
I'm like it's because designing a
machine and intelligence that can deal
with the inanimate world navigating
around rocks on Mars it's fundamentally
different the designing an intelligent
machine that has to interact with
entities whose behavior is governed by
having a mind that was totally different
and nobody was really working on that
problem of robots for the rest of us it
was always autonomous robots as tools
for professionals nobody was really
thinking about autonomous robots in
people's homes were young children to
seniors and everyone in between would be
able to interact and get value from this
kind of technology so that was the
moment and I remember I like marched
into poor and I'm like I have to change
everything I jump stuffing my PhD topic
I'm changing it I'm doing social human
robot interaction and that's when I
started building kismet and he I mean to
Russ credit he was like that's an
important problem go do it now you might
have thought he might have an old
freaked out I have to change everything
but he was always so supportive and he
was always I mean I think one of his you
know greatest strengths he was always a
visionary yeah and he could tell when
there was a problem that was really
worth pursuing so anyway I'm very
fortunate I think to have been and a
student of rod Brookes because he gave
me the freedom to do something crazy
like hizmet which was around this
social-emotional face-to-face
interaction with robots that was
considered kind of crazy at the time
yeah yeah very inspiring I mean you know
having some some time spent at MIT as
well I realized that you know sometimes
you have these ideas which might feel so
out of the box so difficult so for
instance you know when we think about
you know these robots that would be
around inanimate objects like spiders
around rocks you know if you think about
it we know the loss of motions the loss
of physics for almost 300 years now and
even when we don't know those laws you
know building something is so difficult
now you're getting the realm of social
robotics where we don't have these laws
well-defined we're still studying it
don't think it was kind of crazy and
what do you think like given that
difficulty of this challenge what hope
do we have in a completing something
like that in next 5 or 10 years what are
your thoughts on those yeah so I think I
mean certainly as a graduate student
what we had known already from building
these autonomous robots was that people
had a very powerful tendency to want to
add to chrome' or fisa right they didn't
only think about them as kind of useful
tools I mean they really you know
applied what we would call our kind of
social thinking yeah a theory of other
minds and so forth to try to reason
about and make sense of the robot's
behavior so you know one of the key
starting hypotheses was you know if this
is how the human mind naturally is
trying to make sense of this autonomous
behaving entity then what we need to do
is understand that and design to support
the way that people want to think about
and understand and collaborate with
these technologies so it was always a
very human centered human driven process
the other thing of course is that you
know I recognized that trying to model
adult human human interaction was like
yeah you know that's crazy because we
are the most socially emotionally
sophisticated species on the planet so
the thought was what is the simplest
social other that I could model that
adults would still treat as a social
entity and so a lot of that work with
kismet was really inspired by social
development of infant caregiver
interactions it's so much of you know
the developmental psychology is about
the critical roles that we as the caring
nurturing adults play in treating the
infant treating the baby as though he or
she is fully socially intelligent and
capable because it's those interactions
that are needed in order for the child
to learn how to become so you treat as
though so they learn to become and so
that that was the paradigm behind kismet
it was all about this very first
face-to-face social-emotional work where
our communication starts and grow
develops over time so that's kind of how
I I started right just appreciating you
got to start kind of in the in the
primordial aspect of this but
understanding and learning so much and
it's not about you know emotion and
social processes and theory of other
mind processes on a machine I mean
that's like whole new areas of AI now
but also starting appreciate the human
side of that partnership right so in
reading that literature I contrast it so
much today where so many of the AIS we
interact with are very they feel very
transactional they feel very much like
playing chess I say something machine
responds I say something machine
responds communication is not like that
human communication isn't nothing like
that it's a dance and often in a lot of
this literature they talk about the
mother infant dance and it's because the
way we communicate and collaborate is so
dynamic and interwove in' and mutually
regulating that that's what we do in
order to really coordinate states of
mind and behavior that it's always was
always to me at the time that that was
one of the biggest challenges of
creating this kind of socially
collaborative technology was getting the
nuances of that dance right and it's
richly nonverbal in addition to being
verbal in addition to just inferring
these you know invisible states of minds
beliefs intents of desires from watching
human behavior I mean again it's you
know it's it's so again I think one of
the examples that because we as humans
do it so effortlessly we assume it's
easier than it really is I think it's
one of the most sophisticated hardest AI
challenges facing us is understanding
how to create these robots or
intelligent machines that can actually
really collaborate with us
as others you know so sophisticated and
complex and nuanced yeah actually I lose
my mind when I think about the
complexities when I'm interacting with
my you know two-year-old or
five-year-old how sophisticated how
adaptive they are and how quickly they
learn and you have almost you know keep
at pace as their as their as their
growing you know if if you look at the
landscape of you know the recent
advances in machine learning and AI
right you'll see that many of these
successes our data heavy
you know deep machine learning you know
hundreds and millions of data points and
trials and images and sound recordings
and given the complexity of the problem
that you just described I mean can you
comment on you know is data the way to
go there or are there other mechanisms
that we should think about that goes
beyond the realm of just collecting and
or doing some kind of reinforcement
learning for instance sure I mean I
think you know the punchline is way more
right yeah so like you know even you
know again when I started reading and
studying a lot of the infant psychology
it was very apparent that even despite
all our evolutionary advantages and
endowments when we are born into the
world there's a lot of machinery up
there right it's not just data it's a
lot of machinery a lot of structure that
when we gain the experience from the
world that's what allows us to actually
learn the right kinds of things so it's
got to be a combination of the right
cognitive emotional social kind of
mechanisms married with the experience
that is what really kind of makes this
happen and we of course we also know
that you know in tragic situations where
infants don't receive enough social
interaction they become you know
irrevocably severely so even
again for ourselves if we don't get the
right interaction with others in the
social world we need the kind of
scaffolding of empathetic other to help
us learn on the right path so I think
that was just you know again very
eye-opening for me and just very kind of
cognizant as we try to create these AI
so deep learning of course has been
hugely successful and there's still a
lot I guess a lot of runway for deep
learning but you know it is about you
know large data sets and pre labeled
data sets which is very you know
labor-intensive to create there's a lot
of kind of data that doesn't readily
exist right now so when you talk about
this interpersonal mutual regulated kind
of dynamics of interaction that has to
be learned from experience there may be
ways of simulating that to get a
bootstrap up on that but human behavior
again is so rich in new austin diverse
you still I think are gonna need real
interaction in order to learn the right
kinds of behaviors and mechanisms so I
do think reinforcement learning is going
to be important I think it's clear that
you know we can also make these
inferences right so the theory of other
mind sorts of challenges I mean it's
it's ways of even you know simulating as
a way of reasoning and predicting I
think our other sets of mechanisms that
we use empathy the ability to learn by
watching others taking their perspective
kind of using their experience as a
surrogate for your own experience it's
social learning is a whole other suite
of many different kinds of social
learning that we use so I you know again
I think we we have so many ways of
understanding the world in so many ways
of learning from experience that it's
gonna be you know an orchestra of these
kinds of methods to really get to the AI
that we you know associate with being
kind of like the social emotional
intelligent creature that we can
collaborate with we're just scratching
the surface yeah you know just
scratching the surface yes definitely in
fact you know it reminds me of you know
when you were doing the work on kismet
you know you had mentioned that you know
one of the reasons that yeah you know
kismet doesn't talk because you know
it's depicting the state of the
technology you know it's still an
infancy so it's appropriate for us to
basically talk to an infant and you know
it's been almost 20 years since that
work what's your sense of what are the
things that have evolved and are we
still at a state of infancy or has the
technology matured what's your so you
know I think the technology has advanced
of course a great deal and yet it still
has a long way to go right so you know
when we started with kismet you know you
couldn't it was very very difficult to
be able to have robust ASR automatic
speech recognition you know the machine
vision was very primordial you know I
think one of the the most exciting
things that's happened more recently is
just the performance and affordability
of those core technologies have advanced
of the state although they're far from
perfect they're interesting enough that
you can start to create services
products whatever you want to call it
that actually are interesting to people
right they can certainly get a lot
better a lot more sophisticated but at
least you can start to build real
systems that are actually able to
provide value in the world and and in
many ways by doing that just become
painstakingly clear also about the
opportunity and the challenge that still
is ahead to really have these systems
you know meet our visions and our
aspirations for what they'll be able to
be in our lives but just the ability to
build these systems in a way that you
can actually put them in the world it's
hugely important you know and even from
a research standpoint hugely important
because until these systems are in real
real environments were real people
interacting with them you don't really
know what the phenomenon even is that
you're trying to develop for and
understand so so that's been tremendous
you know in fairly recent right and even
right now I would say whatever 43
million neocon of smart speakers in
people's homes now people are living
with AI in a way they never did before
and who is interacting with AI is
fundamentally different it used to be
just kind of like people where goes yeah
now it's young children and seniors and
everyone in between and we know very
little about how to design for the
diversity of needs and opportunities of
such wide demographics and we still
don't understand what this long-term
relationship is going to be right we
build these very transactional systems
by and large you know but I think the
next level is kind of the starwars dream
you know the robot sidekick helpful
companion not just a digital assistant
but a helpful companion that is with you
and works with you towards your goals
and and it really is your collaborator
that's still I think where where this is
going right to me that's like a whole
other layer beyond where we are right
right so you know I've been following
you know your work with the course of
the time and one thing I've realized
that you know there is a little bit of
emphasis on you know building robots of
the form such that you know you interact
with them for instance they'll have eyes
they'll have some kind of you know
capability of you know making some kind
of sound expressions etc you know and
you contrast that to something like you
know smart speakers that you talked
about and what role do you think you
know such you know for the lack of
better word I'm using the word of an
throw answer more fire station for
instance right you know basically is
important in establishing you know like
social rapport with the absolutely yeah
so so I think you know over you know the
the decades of science that's been done
in this field I mean there's been so
many rigorous randomized controlled
trials literally comparing a physically
embodied robot with various cues and
affordances to graphical agents on a
screen to voice only agents and now more
easily into talking speakers that I
think you know the data and the evidence
is pretty clear that the co physical Co
presence social emotional embodiment of
the technology actually makes a
significant difference and how people
engage with it and again it's just
speaking to the fact that we have
evolved specialized neural structures to
do the social thinking and inference
with another that when you create a
technology that gives us those hooks our
minds engage with it and a much richer
deeper way and so if you can have that
depth of engagement when people can
invest more of themselves and the
multiple ways we have of understanding
and reasoning and engaging with
something not just cognitive but the
social and emotional and even the
physical as well the more successful
often we actually are because we're just
able to put more of ourselves into that
interaction I think that's one of the
key I think consistent insights from a
lot of the work that's been done now how
human is another question right and so
I think this is an important point
because there's been kind of this
assumption that the more plug compatible
human the better and I actually don't
think that's that's panned out in the
data I think you know there is there is
a different kind of relationship that
people can have with another that's a
nonhuman other so you think about
companion animals right we can have
meaningful beneficial relationships with
non-human entities and in fact one of
the you know most profound things I
think about companion animals is the
fact that you can have this relationship
that you feel is non-judgmental and it's
just it's a different kind of social
emotional support so that's just to say
that you can design a robot a machine
that does not have to be human-like to
have actually a really important kind of
interaction relationship that provides
tremendous value to the person so we
intentionally
design our robots to be anthropomorphic
to be familiar enough that it can tap
into the social thinking processes of
the way that our brains you know are
wired to work without trying to overstep
and being too human
because it actually starts to set up a
whole host of expectations that first of
all I think we would not be able to
uphold secondly from a philosophical
standpoint I feel like we've got a lot
of people why do we want to make robots
look like people it's like people are
people what what the intriguing design
challenge here is how to create a
technology that complements and
dovetails and augments who we are and
what we do well I suppose to try anymore
okay what we are right so for me that's
a philosophical stance but I definitely
been finding that in creating non-human
anthropomorphic like robots has opened
up huge opportunities for a different
kind of relationship a far more
humanistic experience a relationship
with technology that actually empowers
people so again I think it's it's one
thing to use a useful tool it's another
thing to interact
with an empathetic support of other and
different ways we engage the world are
unlocked when we engage with an
empathetic support of others so when you
look at things like around behavior
change or learning something new or
aging with independence these are all
domains where the social and emotional
support are critical for our well-being
for ability to flourish we need to be
able to extend the kind of services and
support that people provide either as
family members or as professionals you
may be able to get world class kind of
support and intervention in the
institution but what's missing now is we
can't bring that same quality of care to
the home and so when you think about the
opportunity of scalable affordable
high-quality personalized services and
support in the home that's hugely
empowering I would love to have a
personal tutor for my son living with us
a teaching Mandarin I can't afford that
right but with the right kind of AI
that's possible and I think you know we
just live in a time where people just we
need we need help you know we need help
in order to just you know to be able to
fill our opportunity to open up
opportunity you know that to me that's
one of the biggest promises of this
technology is really supporting people
to you know have the opportunity to
become who we aspire to be you know and
and I think the democratization of that
kind of services and support is going to
be critical in making that accessible to
to everyone to you know have an AI you
know for AI think to truly fulfill its
potential it needs to be able to truly
benefit everyone you know and as part of
that I feel it's not only enough that we
try to design this kind of humanistic AI
with that in mind but also we need to
empower children people of all ages to
understand this technology right so you
know I'm a big advocate now of k12 AI
education because children now are not
just digital natives they're AI natives
right they're growing up now where
they've always been able to talk to
intelligent machines people don't
understand enough of what this
technology is they need to understand
they need to grow up feeling empowered
that they can create with it and so I
think this is also really important so
you know if only a small subset of a
population is knowledgeable enough to
create solutions by definition it's only
going to serve a narrow part of the
population and that's just that's going
to exacerbate any divide not close it so
so I think a lot about the
democratization of a on how you empower
you know many many many more people to
create solutions of personal
significance through this technology
yeah no you know when you talk about you
know yeah fulfilling this ambitious goal
and one of the things that that occurs
to me is that we are asking this
technology to actually do many things
well together you know it's being about
safe speech recognition or recognize
social cues or take actions or help us
drive on the street safely etc etc but
as a as a species we've been we excelled
at engineering where that was you know
very well defined goal so for instance
you know let's build cars let's build
bridges let's build airplanes but now
we're talking about a technology that
needs to do many things well so you know
from a design standpoint like how do you
think about building such technologies
like are the certain principles in your
work that you have you know you'd have
found out that that you know we should
be aware of and we should think about
those yeah so I mean I would definitely
you know in the nature of my work so you
know the core of my work is really about
how do you create the human machine
partnership right that I think the core
fundamentals that cut across any sort of
purpose or problem to be solved is what
nature of intelligence and capability
does the machine need to have to support
this human partnership and there's a lot
we can learn from psychology around you
know you know the role of these
nonverbal cues to how you infer goals
and intents and desires and how you get
that from language and like all of these
kind of again the social and emotional
intelligence of the machine and that is
like a very rich relatively very
underexplored area of AI but I think
that's like that's the foundation that
cuts across all of it if you want to
create collaborative
technologies that empower people then
you get down to the specific purposes
right and there may be multiple purposes
but then there's a whole other host of
design decisions you may make depending
on how focused or broad that needs to be
so there's I think a core set of social
emotional intelligence challenges that
again we're still in our infancy of
understanding and then there's
understanding how that intersects with
the the affordances of the utility and
function that you know which would have
influence the nature of the embodiment
and the sensors and the other kind of
knowledge and machine learning out you
know that would go into creating that
but I think you know when we were
graduate students I think it may still
be the case there was this bias that
system integration wasn't interesting
that building the system that wasn't
research that was just engineering that
the science was something different
right I think now maybe we're starting
to deeply understand that the building
the whole brain body sousou is actually
really hard research and we got to start
thinking about the integration of all of
these things rather than thinking we can
go deep in neuro when a core capacities
and think you know you just put you
stick it together and it solved it's
like no that's not the case and then you
have to put it in the world yeah and now
you see how people engage with it
there's a whole other host of learnings
I think you gotta figure out yeah so I
mean it's we live in interesting times
you know the whole area of Robotics
social and emotional robots is you know
as you said it's incredibly difficult
engineering challenge so you know one
final parting question one final
question that I wanted to ask you is
that for someone who aspires to be in
this field who wants to work with
robotics who wants to work about think
about you know the society and effective
systems and things like those the
barrier to entry right now is quite high
right and in the spirit of democratizing
for instance AI and machine links to the
world you know how an aspiring student
should think about you know do you have
any advices I do and any word of advice
with them yeah I think you know so
that's also why I'm so passionate about
you know even pre-k pre-k 12
education because I want to make these
experiences accessible for many many
more kids much earlier on I think right
now you know based on when we were kids
you know we had Lego right now there's
Mindstorms and there's crash and there's
all these other kinds of ways that kids
can actually get into coding and
programming and interacting with this
technology which is is phenomenal we
need to bring it into schools it needs
to come into our k12 formal education
process
there's movements to try to bring
computer science and with that I think
we want to bring in AI education I just
think that's important just to make the
opportunity available to people there
are a lot of after-school activities you
know there are a number of products on
the market there's a lot of things you
can do online I think you know the good
news is there's ways that you can start
to get your hands dirty with this kind
of stuff and what we really want to do
is just make that richer and and more
empowering I think for kids to be able
to apply that honestly at all ages to
things that matter to them because I
think that's when you really start to
develop empathy and you start to
appreciate that creating solutions is
not just this field or that field or the
other but it's how they all come
together and we're both from the Media
Lab so we you know we're already
Commerce of multidisciplinary thinking
but you know to build real things that
are impact real people's lives the
insights and the ways of understanding
across these disciplines they have to
come together and that's when you really
come up with the solutions I think that
that makes sense but building that
empathy and that ability to have those
conversations and the appreciation of
those different ways of thinking and
understanding is also really important
yeah great
thank you for taking the time I enjoyed
the conversation yeah thank you